a reject nation Greg outlet back at it
again marvels Jessica Jones season two
official trailer is here a show comes
out in March Jessica Jones out of all
the defenders was my second favorite
show second two daredevil let's check
this bad boy out the end of x-men
origins
[Music]
[Music]
oh how interesting
the only way to find it is to open the
door wider cool
[Music]
[Music]
there is a killer you cannot control I
didn't ask for any of this
Jessica might not want a psychic but she
[Music]
[Laughter]
what no Zack kilgrave no March 8 damn
well definitely gonna be doing reactions
and reviews for this show man cannot
wait to see this I have a strong feeling
this is gonna be a great season looking
at this show I remember back to first
season to Jessica Jones I noticed that
they usually do like a flashback episode
that really shows you some type of
origin we didn't really get that with
Jessica Jones in the first season they
talked about her past
talk about how she was experimented on
and you get a flashback of what letter -
encountering kilgrave for the first time
you don't really know much about her
history and so watching this trailer
actually got me really intriguing oh
yeah they sure didn't cover any of that
now we're gonna be uncovering her entire
history or entire past which seems
intense and scary
we know Jessica as the depressed
alcoholic in the group and emotionally
closed off it's probably linked to more
than just the events that happened with
kilgrave it's must be linked to
everything that occurred even before
that and Tricia has a line in here where
she's talking about Jessica you know
maybe getting a sidekick I know they've
kind of been building up Trish Walker a
bit and I know in the comic book she
becomes Hellcat I don't know if she'll
dawn a Hellcat costume in here but I
wouldn't mind seeing more of Trish
Walker involved in the show there's some
interesting images in here that I was
noticing - like there's one shot where
she's in the jail cell and then you know
she jessica has superhuman strength
means she can get cut she can't bleed
but she does punch a wall which
shouldn't cause her fish to bleed but
she's talking about how looking into all
this stuff can get her worse so I don't
know if that's like weakening her in
some way whatever she passed she's going
down because her fist starts to bleed
like the way this trailer is advertising
the show it looks like as the seasons
gonna keep going Jessica's emotional
state is gonna keep getting worse she
looks like she's on the brink of
exploding emotionally and remember this
Asian guy is and she was talking about
eliminating the competition I wonder if
this guy is gonna be the main central
bad guy of the season because they kept
cutting back to him they get into fights
with each other you do see Kerry
and moss in this trailer she's kissing a
different girl in here so glad she got
to make out with another chick but
comparing this to the marketing of the
first one was a lot about Jessica Jones
versus kill Griff cuz that's what the
season was really about in this season
that are talking about they're hinting
at stuff of you know take down a monster
you got to become a monster so obviously
there's gonna be another villain in this
season they have it has to be but the
primary focus is all about uncovering
the deep dark roots of Jessica's past
which sounds awesome to me it keeps it
very character-driven and in line with
everything they set up from season one
and the tease of it possibly being
kilgrave at the end I think I heard that
the actor is coming back for this season
I imagine that he's not gonna actually
be back I'm assuming they'll probably be
in the form of either a flashback or
some type of hallucination either way
I'm glad to see him alright guys well
when this show drops we will definitely
be covering this show I cannot wait to
see it you guys can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell get notified every time one of our
videos is up and check out our picture
become a patron object today a lot of
exclusive perks over there